so without further Ado it is my pleasure
to introduce and welcome Dr fauci for
his last uh his last run at the podium
if all you always talked about you
I'll let other people judge the value or
not of my accomplishments but what I
would like people to remember about what
I've done is that every day for all of
those years I've given it everything
that I have and I've never left anything
on the field so if they want to remember
me whether they judge rightly or wrongly
what I've done I gave it all I got for
many decades protection got April and
then Alex all the vaccines safe that
keeps coming up the answer is now
overwhelmingly it should be off the
table there have been 13 billion doses
of a covid-19 vaccine that have been
distributed worldwide hundreds of
millions in the United States and
there's robust safety monitoring systems
that are in place and clearly an
extensive body of information clearly
indicates that they're safe next are
they effective I and I believe you were
all aware of this if you look at the
Striking data overwhelmingly show the
effective business of vaccines
particularly in preventing severe
illness and deaths and recent data that
has come out indicate that if in fact
you are vaccinated and boosted compared
to an unvaccinated person there's a 14
times lower risk of dying in the most
recent
ba45 era
compared to unvaccinated and at least
the three times lower risk of testing
positive compared to the unvaccided
individuals we've all lived through
almost three years of the most
horrendous outbreak that we've
experienced as a society in well over
100 years but there are certain things
that stand out I mean I could probably
write an essay on all the things that
were difficult time but one of the
things as a physician
whose goal in life is to care for
patients and to prevent and treat
illness and ameliorate suffering is that
I remember back in my days in medical
school and when I was an intern and a
resident
when a patient came in whether or not
the patient didn't like you was angry
with you whether it was a rich person or
a poor person you treated everybody the
same because you cared about them and
you wanted everyone to walk out healthy
so when I see people in this country
because of the divisiveness in our
country of not getting vaccinated for
reasons that have nothing to do with
public health but have to do because of
divisiveness and ideological differences
as a physician it pains me because I
don't want to see anybody get infected I
don't want to see anybody hospitalized
and I don't want to see anybody die from
covid whether you're a far-right
Republican or a far-left Democrat
doesn't make any difference to me I look
upon it the same way as I did in the
emergency room in the middle of New York
City when I was taking care of everybody
that was coming in off the street so
that's the thing that troubles me most
about this I think we're going is that
sooner or later and I hope it's sooner
we're going to equilibrate to a low
level when there's enough background
cross protection that unless we get a
completely far way out different variant
we likely going to see a continued low
ring lowering maybe we're going to see
blips at winter and stuff but hopefully
it gets down the message that Dr jar and
I are trying to get to you today is that
we can make that happen much sooner by
vaccinating and by keeping updating on
your booster it's just really as simple
as that we're going to get there we can
get there with less suffering if we use
the interventions that we have if you
want to let nature take its course we're
ultimately going to get there but we're
going to lose a lot more people than we
need to the way you counter
misinformation and disinformation is
that to do whatever you can as often as
you can to provide correct information
the people who have correct information
and who takes science seriously who
don't have strange way out theories
about things but who base what they say
on evidence and data need to speak up
more because the other side that just
keeps putting out misinformation and
disinformation seems to be tireless in
that effort and it's going to be very
difficult the answer is if there are
oversight hearings I absolutely will
cooperate fully and testify before the
Congress have asked you may not know but
I've testified before the Congress a few
hundred times okay over the last 40
years or so so I have no trouble
testifying we can defend and explain and
stand by everything that we've said so I
have nothing